[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm scott oswald i'm the creative
director of the mit education arcade
but i'm turning the floor over to vic
bald who's our director of graduate
studies and
he'll be doing the introduction so great
thank you um so it's it's my great
pleasure to introduce laura partain
tonight um laura is a visiting lecturer
in
in our department in comparative media
studies this year
uh specifically in civic and global
media
so laura is a media effects scholar
whose work focuses on understanding the
complex
the complex news and social media
effects on marginalized communities
access to socio-political material
and medical resources her scholarship
is located at the interstices of
citizenship status
and national belonging laura's research
uses experimental analyses to develop
media interventions
for prejudice reduction and focuses on
the media effects
of racial religious and ethnic identity
representations
laura has worked with communities in
syria the occupied palestinian
territories
lebanon and iran but also works with
these communities
who are forcibly displaced in diaspora
that is refugees
and asylum seekers as well as with arab
and muslim americans
more broadly her training in critical
study
is in critical studies um and uh
her use of interview and survey method
methods
grounds her work within these
communities experiences
while necessarily considering these
communities in relation
to geopolitics and other transnational
solidarity movements
she is a phd candidate in indiana
university's media school
holds an m.a in middle eastern studies
from the university of texas austin
and graduated with a ba in religious
studies
from the university of wisconsin-madison
laura is also a fellow in the muslim
women and the media institute
through a henry luz grant at uc davis
and i'm going to hand it over to laura
welcome
i said great thank you so much vivek uh
can i go ahead and share my screen now
so that i can um
launch right into my powerpoint
wonderful okay
so i'm now screen sharing
and there we go can everyone see is
every everything good
okay so i have a lot to get through um
there may be certain points where i kind
of briefly touch on the slides and then
move on
uh if you have any questions about what
i've moved on from quickly or skipped
over entirely
uh please feel free to ask me about
those slides or that information in the
q
a session so this project that i'm going
to be discussing today is called dynamic
exchanges
um and yeah it so this project
um really uh came out of the
2015-2016 presidential election cycle
um and um the rhetoric that occurred
during that
election cycle but also very much so the
policies
and the facilitation of certain policies
um that happened once
uh donald trump was elected to president
right so
um one of the first things that donald
trump
uh did when after his election to the
presidency
was he put out executive order 13769
and this order
um effectively banned
communities from muslim majority
countries and and this is why it became
known as the quote-unquote muslim ban
and it became known as this primarily
because it
seemingly um inconsistently and randomly
um selected certain countries uh to be
banned from entrance to the united
states while allowing other
muslim majority countries to still have
access to um
immigration or or uh to visit the united
states
so the goal of this was according to the
white house to protect the nation from
for
foreign terrorist entry into the united
states
um so uh along with this order
um very shortly thereafter uh donald
trump also talked
a lot about the preferred immigrants or
desired immigrants um that he would like
to come to the united states
and he would alway or he put those
in a binary between
the [ __ ] countries um which he most
commonly
talked about for example like haiti or
other countries on the african continent
and then norway um and so he he really
created this binary between them that
the only conceivable way to understand
the binary
was through a lens of race
and this comment or this
dialogue that he started on these
countries
uh was followed up by his immigration or
his head of immigration
kevin cuccinelli um giving us a rewrite
on the uh statue of liberty's uh
kind of infamous um uh symbolism
uh in that he said uh she really should
be saying give me you're tired and
you're poor who can stand on their own
two feet
and who will not become a public charge
uh so um with this
uh kind of whole set of rhetoric coming
out
and the public charge um order being put
in place
uh this resulted in a number of uh on
the ground
fax for certain marginalized communities
such that
uh especially immigrants um became
nervous
and um in some instances would try to
take their children off like their
health care
because they would they worry that that
would disqualify them
from being able to have access to
permanent residency or to get a green
card
this had additional effects on their
access to food stamps
cash assistance public housing programs
and right now we can see the way that
this rhetoric and subsequently the
policies that came out of this rhetoric
have had repercussions for these
communities
uh specifically immigrant communities
and
those who are undocumented but also
those who are for example asylum seekers
and um it has kind of created this
freeze on them not knowing whether they
could or could not seek
uh health care assistance um for coved
or during um the the pan the period of
the pandemic
um and um uh immigration
websites in the us have taken to putting
a lot more information up online
uh that uh tries to assure people that
they can seek assistance
but i'm bringing this up because of
um the way that my work in particular
at this stage is seeking to really
analyze the
immediate rhetorical effects on
audiences
and to then be able to take that
information and see how it translates
into public policy and then uh kind of
dictates or
restricts certain access to resources
i'm gonna go ahead and move forward so
um
we are most of us are probably quite
familiar with the rhetoric that
occurred during the election cycle
these images represent some of the
rhetoric that was used to discuss syrian
refugees
um ranging from ben carson uh
saying that syrian refugees were like
a rabid dog um to
the very frequently used idea that
syrian refugees were acting as a trojan
horse
um for isis um and so
this type of rhetoric was very common
and even still
kind of perpetuates the discourse on
syrian refugees
there also so while there was not
necessarily as much discourse on
palestinians
in this last election cycle there has
historically
been quite a bit of discourse that has
fundamentally excluded the voices of
palestinians
as well as ignored
some of their some of their demands or
desires
um for self-determination during
presidential debates
um and even though donald trump did not
discuss palestinians
um or really as much israel during his
presidential election cycle
since he took office he
has moved the u.s embassy from tel aviv
in israel to jerusalem
and he's also put out the deal of the
century
along with his son-in-law jared kushner
that
again did not seek the input of any
palestinian voices
and by and large um ignored
or inappropriately addressed
historical conditions for palestinians
some sort of palestinian peace deal with
israel
so this
research then that i'm presenting to
today is called dynamic exchanges
because as i've demonstrated briefly
already but
what i want to hit home today is that
when a news media object or a news media
product or a media product in general is
put out
that there isn't just one instance or
one site of consumption that happens
that oftentimes what we see is that
something is put out
in the media and then you have a certain
audience who consumes that and then that
audience
may react to that object or product
um in their consumption and then
reproduce it again for other people to
consume or respond to
so what happens is you typically have
this cycle of
different sites of production
consumption and then reproduction
and all of these impact the rhetoric
that
uh that immigrants that middle eastern
and arab communities navigate every day
and i just briefly want to point out
that i do use the phrase middle eastern
there are also other phrases
um that some people that are somewhat
contentious
i know that middle eastern for example
um to some people
they see it as a reflection of uh
colonial discourse
um and unfortunately a lot of the terms
we use are imperfect
and uh but for the sake of being able to
have this discussion and refer to a
specific area today i'm going to use
middle eastern uh so
um i will be talking about uh
the cycle that i'm referring to um and
the question
that i developed to address this cycle
is what are the news media facts of
presidential rhetoric and policy at
different sites of a media cycle
um so i'll address this through an
experiment that i conducted
uh this experiment was with native born
u.s citizens who um
turned out to be about 87 white
um then i conducted a survey with
uh palestinian and syrian syrian
americans
um and in that survey i presented to
them the results of the experiment
as well as sought their feedback on the
original
news object and then i also conducted
interviews
um with uh syrian americans and
palestinian-american artists
uh to get a better in-depth look at some
of the responses to
um the media ecosphere and to to better
understand
the types of production or artistry that
they put out
um in light of uh in light of the
rhetoric
so i'm gonna give a brief project
introduction
so this project examines established
differences in the us
historical narrative that privilege
legible
otherness often represented through
assumed visual markers
differences such as race and nationality
contribute to in-group and out-group
stereotypes
that mobilize political and social
marginalization
despite the supposed coherency of
in-group and out-group divisions
this project raises research questions
that examines degrees of such divisions
creating a comparative analysis between
communities that are often subsumed into
the single category
of middle eastern arab or muslim
this work offers a complicated look into
the embeddedness of ideological messages
about race religion and national
belonging within u.s culture
seemingly incoherent my results on race
nationality and religion
are decipherable through a lens of
whiteness that upholds
historical systems of oppression i
assess these results through a framework
of what my research has constructed as a
quote-unquote politics of gratitude
which i term as a set of extrajudicial
expectations
that native born u.s citizens or native
born citizens place
on a immigrant or refugee
using this construct to demonstrate how
the figure of the arab
enforced migrant destruct disrupt
established hierarchies in u.s social
space
and how u.s religion and racial systems
are two integral points
through which subsequent marginalization
occurs
so some of the relevant theories that i
use throughout my research
of which i previously had kind of
interspersed throughout
my slides but i realized that it would
be best just to put it at the beginning
so everyone can kind of understand where
i'm going with some of this
um so i use something called social
identity theory and i talked a lot about
in my introduction
um in groups and out groups and social
identity in theory
uh really informs the ways that we
um informs the process of how we
construct or why we construct those in
groups in our groups
so this theory is premised on the idea
that our individuals
desire to have a positive self-concept
concept and manage or improve
their self-esteem accordingly there are
negative or positive attributes
associated with varying social group
categories
and these associations are relevant to
one's own self-concept
so when one has an in-group and one has
an out group
there are going to be different
ideas that are attributed to one group
versus the other group
and the idea here is that those concepts
or those attributions
uh can be um
that it affects the way that one sees
oneself and one sees one's in group
right so third social groups are not
inherently positive or negative but
accrue these
evaluations based on comparisons to
other social groups
so the idea really is that we all want
to have a positive self-concept
and therefore we want to have our group
that we use the groups that we belong to
have a positive
construct as well i also talk about
something that is not technically called
museumization but i
label it as such and it's from
chakrabarty
uh and he discusses the way that
whiteness establishes itself as the
authoritative voice in teleological
global development
and um this is really uh necessary
for my work and thinking about ideas of
progress or liberalism um and
how uh within this construct
um communities such as from the middle
east are always put
as always already behind
and failing to live up to a set of
expectations
because of of this design in development
so i also use theories on whiteness to
really inform my work
and um whiteness uh defined by bab is a
system of privileges
according to those with white skin um
uh importantly dyer says that it's not
just epidermal markers of a vague
otherness this is not a direct quote
um it's not just epidural epidermal
markers of a vague otherness
outward markings of difference came to
stand in for a symbolic negation of
whiteness
that is a moral irrational unintelligent
inhumane and unchanging
um and these uh constitute whiteness
through the very absence
of european designated spiritual or
intellectual integrity
so um according to yancey the
intentional de-historic
de-historicization of whiteness veiled
its composition
as natural rather than as aspirational
and subsequently reordered the
ontological
and epistemological ways of knowing
morality intellectualism
and rationalism so by fundamentally
devaluing indigenous knowledge
that included spiritual modes of
discovery and analysis
scientific rationalism decidedly
positioned alternative ways of knowing
as outside the very boundaries of
rational thought itself
the schematics of this institution were
self-sustaining
if by a system that white ruling classes
created
indigenous and black communities were
naturally less intelligent
rational and moral then these same
communities were always already
precluded from disputing the very
validity
of racial science that legitimized
equivocations of whiteness with
prosperity
and these ideas are going to become
really relevant as we move into
understanding
some of the results of the experiment
that i
am about to present so my experimental
research
was presented to participants as
a news story and this is an example down
here of how it was presented
um there were different uh hosts or
different um
news anchors there were different images
and representations
so as to reduce potential bias towards a
single image
it was represented here as a news story
and represented two participants as
coming straight from the news
um although later it was corrected to
inform participants that
indeed these stories represent kind of
an amalgamation of different news
stories about syrian refugees or
palestinian refugees but that they
actually uh they
this wasn't like a direct or or an
actual story that had happened
so um i my experiment was
a three-level experiment
i used something called moral mappings
of which i'm not going to get
too in-depth into um but this comes from
something called moral foundations
theory which is
predicated on the idea that there are a
finite
essentially a finite amount of
moral foundations or outlooks
that influence the way that people see
the world in the way that they interact
with the world
so for example um um i i took these
ideas and then i matched them with
presidential rhetoric
um that occurred during the presidential
election cycle
um and so if a
candidate talked a lot about police or
talked a lot about um the military for
example
uh that would reflect an idea of
authority subversion and that was
maybe would be used there so then um
another manipulation of manipulations um
are nationalities
so i manipulated whether people received
um a condition with
a palestinian story a syrian story or a
norwegian story
and i also manipulated racial phenotype
as well
so accompanying every story that the
people received
they would receive two images one with
presidential rhetoric and one with a
story about a refugee or immigrant
family trying to resettle in the u.s
um every story would have um one
either one image either of a syrian
family
with a lighter phenotype or with a
darker phenotype
so the categories of hypotheses that i
looked at pertain to
rhetoric nationality and race as can be
reflected
in the experimental design
i measured participants emotional
reactions their expectations
as well as their specific attitudes
towards refugees and immigrants
i went through i collected a lot of
demographic data
and i ran this experiment if anyone
who's in quantitative studies is
interested i ran it
um as a single motto with the three
manipulations as well as the
participants own
religious affiliations
so for some of the demographic results
um when
i conducted this i did allow people to
select
really like 20 from 27 different
religious variables
um so for example jewish denominations
were broken up into
you know orthodox conservative or
reformed jewish
um but uh by and large um almost
everyone concentrated in these three
categories which were
um i i recoded to be kind of an atheist
agnostic non-religious
there were very few participants in the
jewish denomination but i thought it was
important to keep
that and then also i had christian
denominations racially
um it was again like i said
predominantly
um made up of white participants
and the education level people were
fairly highly educated who participated
in this but we also had a kind of a nice
spread of people from different
um educational backgrounds also a fairly
nice spread in terms of age although
once again
uh we had i had mostly a younger a set
of younger people taking this
um in terms of nationalism
um we i had uh
again fairly high levels of people who
held nationalist ideas
um participate in the study and then for
their political identities
um it was about a two to one ratio of
people who were
democrat taking this um and then quite a
few people who didn't support any
political parties which i was a little
surprised by but maybe i shouldn't be
um quite as much given the current um
state of politics so um some of the
results that i found
which these really are some of the
results because i i want to note that
um i was examining quite a few things
and i did
find results for the moral manipulations
as well as things more pertaining to the
nationality
of the um refugees but by and large
the results that i found or the results
that i'm presenting which make up the
core
of the analysis um have to do
with race and um the religion of the
uh people who took the experiment
so um for uh kind of a breakdown
there were a lot of positive reactions
um when people received the darker
phenotype representation
such that they were more likely to
believe that this refugee story was
reliable or truthful
they were more likely to believe that
the us should welcome refugees and
immigrants
in general and they held significantly
higher levels of
feelings like feeling disturbed over u.s
policies demonizing refugees and
immigrants
um i almost reached a level of
significance
but um this is still an important
finding that
um people who received darker phenotype
representations
uh were almost more likely to support
the assertion that people have a right
to flee their homes of origin
they were more likely to support refugee
and immigrant resettlement
they felt sadder for the refugee
families in the story and they also held
significantly higher feelings of
acceptance
um towards the refugee the refugee
family
people who received the lighter
phenotype
representations were um more likely to
agree with the statement that
white muslims are less violent than
brown muslims because they are still
culturally more similar to the west
um they were less likely to receive the
lighter phenotype versus the darker
phenotype
they were less likely to agree with the
statement that it would be foolish for
muslims to demand access to all levels
of society
which once again the flip side of that
is that people who received the darker
phenotype were statistically more likely
um to believe that muslims that it was
foolish for them to demand
equality to all aspects of society um
those who receive the lighter phenotype
also um believe they could recognize
um a muslim by their physical appearance
alone
and they're almost less likely to hold
neoliberal expectations
which are a set of um uh expectations
that have to do with
public role or like reliance on um
certain government support um for
refugees and immigrants
so right so even though i have more
things to get through just as a summary
what we can kind of see
here for the racial for when people
received
um the darker phenotype representation
by and large they had more of an
altruistic or a sympathetic response
to the uh refugee family and towards
immigrants and refugees in general
um when they received the lighter
phenotype representation
people were more likely to display
anti-muslim
racism attitudes and to
kind of show more of a preference for um
lighter phenotype or have higher better
more
nicer if you will views towards lighter
phenotype
refugees and immigrants in terms of the
religions of facts
what i found was were mostly differences
between
um christians and ignat and the group
that is
um agnostic or atheist or non-religious
um and so um
you know just for anyone again who runs
statistics there's interested in the
quantitative aspect of this they did run
post-hoc analyses to ensure that there
were significant differences between
those two groups and that it wasn't just
something thrown off by there being a
smaller um group of
the jewish community participating in
the survey so
this is mostly comparison comparing the
christian
groups and the non-religious groups
so that means that christians were less
likely to believe that immigrants and
refugees had a right to challenge u.s
um they
were less likely to believe that
immigrants and refugees should have
input on their treatment um they were
less likely to support resettlement
in general then they were less likely to
be disturbed over negative rhetoric
about these communities
they are more likely to believe there
should there should be higher legal
standards
for immigrants and refugees they are
more likely to support an english
requirement prior to resettlement
they are more likely to hold anti-muslim
racist sentiment
and they also were more likely to hold
higher expectations that refugees and
immigrants
assimilate have positive feelings or
attitudes
um and for them to not rely on usaid or
resources
christians were also believed that they
could spot a muslim by physical
appearance alone
and they also thought it was foolish for
muslims to have access
to all levels of society
um additionally participants who believe
that
whose faith was more important to them
who believe the u.s should welcome all
faiths equally and who also believe that
the us
is a unique safe haven for christians
and jews over
all had less positive views for his
immigrants and refugees
held higher expectations for immigrants
and refugees
and were less likely to report or to
support resettlement
so we can kind of see even within this
that
people simultaneously believed that the
us
does welcome all faiths equally but then
at the same time also believes that the
us is a unique safe haven
for um uh christians and jews
right and and so we kind of see uh there
being a wrench thrown into some of these
these ideas or
are these world views so then how do we
explain
these seemingly contradictory results
where we have a situation
um where uh where
people seem to have a nicer or more
positive view of lighter phenotype
refugees and immigrants but also really
would prefer to have
um darker phenotype refugees and
immigrants be resettled
how do we kind of rationalize this idea
that christian communities
are um that in the u.s historically
a lot of christian communities have been
the ones who are leading
um the way to have refugees resettled or
who find homes for refugees but then
also
you have a situation where they are the
ones who have
the least positive view between jewish
christian
and non-religious communities in the us
towards these groups
so we can kind of we can understand this
best if we understand it through a lens
of air of american history
right so until the 1960s arab americans
were not considered european white
but they also were not deemed as
antithetical to whiteness itself
nor did they threaten the ideological
integrity of the us racial system
uh interviews that were done with arab
americans in
around the 1960s 1970s 1980s
uh have shown that some arab americans
actually thought
they were perceived as a model minority
um and the raciness
that is the race put on these
communities
living in the us really fluctuated over
time depending on the needs of whiteness
to discipline us citizens and incoming
immigrants
so arab americans avoided being wholly
raced in the u.s not because they were
unidentifiable
as an other indeed many arab americans
were included in categories along with
ottoman turks
greeks italians and other mediterranean
groups based on the context and at a
time when these other groups were not
yet subsumed
into categories of whiteness
they were not yet raced
because the history of arab-american
immigration coincided with moments when
they were permitted
or sometimes demanded of to assimilate
into normative cultural definitions of
whiteness
although this points to the very
fluidity of the us racial epistem itself
arab americans racial adaptability has
been a product of their adjacency to
whiteness
whereby this community at times was able
to legislate their own identities
in a way that african or indigenous
americans for example
could not despite whiteness's
affordances to arab american communities
their subject position was always
determined through white intermediaries
rendering their racial identities both
subjective and often very precarious for
these communities
so the reason that syrian and
palestinian arabs in particular avoided
rigorous racial identification
until the 20th century derives from
shifting immigration policies
that aim to keep as many quote unquote
undesirable immigrants out of the united
states
as possible and we can see this because
if we're looking i pulled up this map to
hopefully be a little bit of a help to
us
and so uh this is early arab immigration
to the u.s
and sorry i'm moving my click around so
you can see it so early lebanese syrian
and palestinian immigrants to the us
were referred to by and large as
syrians and this was due to
this whole area and many often being
referred to as el shems
and u.s citizens uh would just call them
all syrians because they didn't really
understand the complexity of the region
but within this area of al-shams we see
like here is
um syria here is jordan
there is palestine sorry i'm trying to
look um
in lebanon i'm trying to see where it's
listed i believe it's right here
so um what happened was the
inability for people to recognize some
of the differences led them to just be
altogether categories in the us as
syrian for some time
right the first large-scale immigration
um to the us occurred between the 1880s
and 1920s
uh but it's important to note here that
um as alexa naff or alexa naf has
demonstrated in her
fantastic and really foundational work
on arab-american communities
is that um individual arabs had actually
been
uh traveling and immigrating to the us
or traveling back and forth between
the us and in their country of origin
really for several hundreds of years for
several hundred years before that
so around that time we had a number of
immigration restrictions which i wish i
could get into i don't have time to go
for all of them
um but there's the naturalization act of
1790
the chinese exclusion act of 1882 in
1889 that's when the us began using race
specifically as an additional
um immigration category to screen
entrance
into the u.s there was the 1917
immigration act and then also the
johnson reed act of 1924
and then there were additional
immigration acts after that to either
consolidate
um previous immigration acts or to um
change them uh right so
um they so
arab americans did not avoid the early
stages
of specifically racialized violence in
the us because white americans were
benevolent towards this group
but instead because whiteness as an
ideology benefited from categorizing
arabs as temporary citizens of whiteness
for example arab americans have
historically acted as a boundary line
between whiteness
and otherness often stemming from their
unique identities
arabs um have historically been had a
higher socio
than part of a higher socioeconomic um
group they are predominantly middle
class or wealthy landowners and
entrepreneurs
um religiously uh arabs before world war
ii were 95
um christian actually and uh racially
um they were able to once again litigate
their whiteness in courts so as becomes
clear the confluence of racial religious
and presumed cultural identities
have resulted in a contemporary system
whereby
arab whiteness veils systemic
inequalities that this community faces
prevents arab access to resources
designated for marginalized communities
and renders arabs as threatening because
of their ability to assimilate
so if arabs mark the limitations of
whiteness asian communities have
historically precipitating or
precipitated
the hardening of racial boundaries and
we can see that through
some of the cases on litigation that
occurred in the earlier 1900s
um one of the uh first ones was for
acosta
george najer he um
he had lived in the u.s for a long time
but because of an earlier
um earlier acts that said that
chinese-americans could not be
naturalized and he was forced to
litigate his whiteness
um and prove that he was quote unquote
not asiatic
and then in another case in 1910 tom
ellis
also had to try to litigate his
whiteness in court
and it's important to remember that
during this period judges would use a
would fluctuate in what types of
rationale they would use for why someone
was or was not white
whether it be the visual representation
or it be scientific racism
um addition in addition to other
categories
and so for tom ellis he had to
he was on the borderline and what um
allowed the judge to rule in his favor
was that he spoke english which was an
example of his
literacy but also that he was christian
which therefore implied that he had good
moral character um so
what these what this demonstrates is
there um oftentimes that
race is unstable over time but by and
large
that um when arabs were able to litigate
their whiteness they did so at the
expense and
and by the same logic um that really
held up white supremacy at the time
um also again this does not necessarily
mean
that they always benefited from this
rather they were often perceived
by the wider public
not to not be white and there were also
for example
uh situations or cases where arab
americans were lynched as well
so they did not necessarily receive any
sort of positive treatment just because
they were able to
quote litigate their whiteness
okay so um uh
arabs released it in the middle of these
discussions on racial identification
their national identities position them
as belonging to the asian continent
but their phenotypic variation
predominantly christian identities
an economic fit with contemporary
american capitalist
values were in opposition to common
stereotypes about asian communities
that arabs were visibly recognized as
not indigenous or
indigenous american or black but not
commonly accepted as white
led to various attempts to literally get
their whiteness to claim its privileges
as we talked about um so uh arab
americans also
hold on let me here we go arab americans
also relied on christian faith practices
to establish their whiteness in u.s
legal proceedings
and this reaffirms kind of the complex
mutual dependency of national and ethnic
origins
and religious affiliation that
historically constituted race
as natural rather than a construct
although explicit mention of race
uh sorry of religion is often elided
from conversations on race
scholars and whiteness studies
diligently and earth enroll their
religion symbolically and materially
held
in the violent disenfranchisement of
racially marked marginalized communities
in america
scholars target the 1700s and 1800s as a
period where codification of racial
hierarchies in the u.s
took hold so scholarship examines how
the groundwork for race hierarchies
has been in place for centuries that
christians brought a tradition of
the binary of black and white moral
dualism to bear on an enemy
um that could be perceived as black so
the crusades were thus part according to
dyer of a heightening awareness of skin
color differences
which they further inflected in terms of
moral attributes
so what we see here is that over time
and specifically in the united states
christianity had worked to uphold racial
binaries
between whiteness which was associated
with ideas of purity
morality holiness and these same values
that were used to
rationalize slave holding in the united
states
were similarly also used as a way to
perpetuate um taking over
or um the genocide of indigenous
americans as well as u.s
imperialism abroad so really
um in in the u.s um arab americans were
perceived as white by and large until
the quote-unquote question of palestine
in the 1960s um when they were
increasing wars
um between israel and palestinians and
and the other surrounding
arab countries uh and um
between the cold war when um arab
americans and muslim americans
became kind of the new boogeyman and um
in post
9 11 america uh we
we saw again kind of the ratification of
the binary between or the perceived
binary between christian and muslim
communities in the us
so for further information i'd really
recommend these books which are
fantastic on arab immigration
arab americans race and immigration in
general
so some of the takeaway results from
this experiment are really that these
results unveil a system of participant
belief whereby darker phenotype refugees
are more recognizable as victims these
experiment tests are not
examining whether people feel sympathy
overall but they're really based
on the differences uh between when
people received
a darker phenotype image or lighter
phenotype image
so um we we found that um or i found
that
uh by and large those who
are the participants in the study held
more ultra altruistic views
towards darker phenotype refugees and
this evidence
really supports an explanation whereby
the belief that lighter phenotype
individuals
possess inherent character traits that
predisposes them to success
and that failure to live up to the
success is a personal rather than
systemic condition
for example i found that there were
higher expectations that were placed on
lighter phenotype
earth lighter phenotype norwegians and
darker phenotype
syrians so while um their higher
expectations for darker phenotype
syrians
higher expectations were placed on
lighter phenotype norwegians
because of the supposed racial
in-group outgroup differences so here
the us racial hierarchy
really disciplines immigrants and
refugees into
perceived appropriate roles for these
communities
and traits like language racial
phenotype or cultural presentation
are used to mark certain communities as
the other
and therefore requiring additional
surveillance
so for white christian citizens survival
is then predicated on being able to
essentialize
the other and here essentializing um the
other reinforces sameness
so without persisting categories or
categorization of outgroups as
possessing inherent similarities
whiteness really risks the weakening of
its ideology of supremacy
through middle eastern and muslim
communities perpetually demonstrating
cultural religious
linguistic and political differences so
even though
there was more sympathy for darker
phenotype refugees this is also
potentially
because they are markedly the other and
therefore do not
really disrupt systems or coherent
systems of racial hierarchies
um so i'll go through the survey quite
quickly here oh
sorry okay
so i took these experimental results
then and i
presented them to um a uh
participant pool of syrian americans and
palestinian-americans
but before i did that i actually
presented
these groups with the exact same news
story
and i also presented them so with the
news story and then a set of questions
for a new story
and then i presented them with the
results from the experiment
so um i asked them a set of demographic
questions we had about 46 participants
which is a fairly small
demo or fairly small pool of
participants um but we had a really
um a nice spread of people with
different religious beliefs between
non-religious atheists we had sunni
muslim and then
a variety of christian denominations
these communities were from
all over the globe were born in
different places
um they also held very national
or ethnic identities um some of the
other
results that i found is that these
communities by and large
felt really connected to their ethnic
and or national communities
um that they spent a lot of time
practicing or they
spent most of their time relating to
their community through practicing and
artistic activity
um but they also connected to their
communities through other
religious activities or political um and
general social activities
and that um palestinians and syrian
americans
use social media very often to represent
themselves
or represent their national or ethnic
identities and that when they did so
they were most likely to use facebook
and then twitter
so i had a pretty solid amount
of people who identified this was a
self-identification
so people were able to enter in or
select multiple racial identities
um as well as enter in other ones that
they thought
better represented themselves so they um
a lot represent or self-selected brown
as a racial identity or
white as a racial identity and because i
had a smaller
participant pool i then recoded these
into
um even though these names are not quite
like what i would like them to be
um i had to recode them into people who
identified as white only
and then people who identified as
multiple identities or in some way
identified as white in addition to other
um
racial or ethnic identities so i didn't
find importantly
when i used race as
a mode of stratification to understand
the results from the survey
i didn't find any differences according
to race in
how people participated in activity is
there was no difference
in their connections to their identities
or connections to others in the
community
um there was no difference in how they
identified in terms of their citizenship
status
whether it be immigrant asylum seeker or
otherwise
there also was no difference in terms of
how people identified racially
and how they identified religiously or
whether they were born inside and
outside the united states
this is important because these could be
explanatory mechanisms for what i found
because what i did find is that for
participants who identified as white
only
they participated in fewer religious
activities
but they also held higher expectations
for the immigrant and refugee family
that was in the news story
so they were more likely or they um they
held feelings that they expected
the refugee and immigrants to be
grateful to the united states for
letting them in or that they should
leave
they also expected them to be happy and
have feelings of happiness
and general feelings of gratitude right
and they were also
less likely to agree with this statement
that immigrants and refugees
should have input regarding us policies
and treatment of immigrants and refugees
but at the same time when i presented
the survey participants with the results
from the experimental study
which as a reminder was primarily it was
native-born u.s citizens who um 87
of whom were white the participants
who the survey participants who
identified as white only and were more
critical of immigrants and refugees and
held higher expectations of them
they rejected the experimental results
or negative views on their communities
at the same rate as people who didn't
identify as white only
so some of the takeaways from this are
that um
we can understand or that to understand
racial identity and social identity
theory
it really should be complicated by power
structures
and understanding that um that social
identities may actually fluctuate
depending
on who you uh on the information you
receive or who is
uh at a time per again or perhaps
against your in-group
right and i've also um a takeaway would
be that internalized whiteness
may be an important lens with which to
understand contemporary racial and
social politics among marginalized
communities
so i think i have like ten minutes five
minutes
does anyone know quebec do i still have
a few minutes to go over the interview
portion
sorry i was muted yes um
take take the time that you need oh okay
great
okay so the last section oh
the last section then um are the
interviews uh
and these interviews um
were conducted with syrian and
palestinian artists six different
artists
over about 19 hours of talk time
uh and um i
used something called grounded theory to
assess these
or to analyze these interviews
and grounded theory in this case really
centered the
interviewee's own experiences and and
and their demonstration of how their
experiential reality
uh itself is pedagogical and um
uh it's really useful
and also breaking down some of the
historical barriers between
uh the academy and the quote-unquote
real world if you will um so i used
robin gigi kelly's work to kind of
guide that grounded theory and my
research question
um for this was how does a contemporary
us news media ecology affect syrian
american and palestinian-american
artistry
so the artist um the first one is alma
casir
she's pictured right here she's a
syrian-american woman from denver
colorado
she's a poet a spoken word artist a
teacher
she's known for her ted talk she's
performed at the kennedy center
she was also recently representative to
the un international women's day on
behalf of tortured syrian women
the next artist is basil almadani he is
a syrian american man from kent ohio
he is a soul and funk musician as well
as a logistics expert consultant manager
he really yeah all of these artists
i want to um comment on how they all had
multiple jobs and needed to have
multiple jobs but they all had multiple
jobs they spent a lot of their time on
um and i was really grateful for them to
take the time out to talk to me
um so he's known for being the lead
singer for basil in the supernaturals
and they have performed at many a music
venue including south by southwest
um i also talked to tara clefoon he's a
palestinian-american man from detroit
michigan
he's a poet community organizer and a
data analyst
he's known for he won a regional emmy
award
he's also advised on major um uh
political campaigns in michigan
and has been the face of a lot of um
acted local activism in michigan
so one of the other artists is dj fatin
she's a palestinian-american woman from
brooklyn new york
she is a dj an activist um and she's
known for being
the quote unquote uh female palestinian
dj
a title or label which she
kind of rejects but also appreciates for
its sentiment
um she's performed at the kennedy center
she's been
invited to perform at embassies uh she's
she's known
globally um for her dj djayne
um the next person is sierra zala he's
the one who
um painted this mural he's a
palestinian-american man from dearborn
michigan in san francisco california
he grew up between both communities so
he identifies as coming from both
um he's a visual artist who paints
murals
paintings digital art and clothing
among other forms of art he's known for
some of his commissioned art around san
francisco
the us even around the globe and he's
also known for his uh oakland
palestine solidarity mural the last
person that i interviewed was samuel
bain
he is my lebanese syrian palestinian
italian interviewee from san francisco
california
yes he identifies very much with all
four so we didn't limit you know
um and he is with a comedian a host
he does like 50 jobs it's amazing
he's known for um he was one of the
hosts on the netflix show the hundred
humans
um he's been on america's got talent
conan
the last comic standing and he's known
for
his performance of literally a thousand
and one nights of comedy in a row
i don't know how he kept that up so i
talked to them a lot about their
experiences um
with uh producing art and and producing
um important cultural products uh
in light of or during um a time
when uh the news
media sphere and news and media in
general
um produced not quite so kind pred
or ideas or rhetoric about these
communities
and so tarik's conver or tark's thoughts
on this were really
important and useful and so i wanted to
read his thoughts
um rather than kind of outlining a whole
theory of my own here so i think that's
also what's been difficult about being
palestinian about being a person of
color
often you know you're always asked well
how bad is your oppression really
it's like you can't point to one moment
that was racist
i'm like i'm always living under it it's
like i'm always seeing it
i wake up every day knowing that my
family back home has limited resources
and limited access to health care
has limited freedom right so like i wake
up every day knowing this
so when we talk about media portrayals
there isn't one single media moment that
i feel like
impacts me they all weigh me down to a
greater and greater extent with every
passing moment
and so long as we're not free i will
always be weighed down
whether i see it or not you know like
whether i see it or not i know the
perception
i understand the way in which media has
contributed or been complacent and
complicit in the portrayal of my people
so there isn't one moment there isn't
like one time
but i can say that it definitely
frustrates me it definitely
makes you want to it makes you feel like
you're going crazy because
like here you you can see tangible
things that you believe and know are
true
and yet an entire population of people
thinks that your truth is not real
and so this was a sentiment that was
expressed widely among the participants
the idea that um the
the media and here most often referring
to american media
gaslit them and um made them feel like
what they were seeing what they were
experiencing
wasn't really what the reality was and
so this was something that a lot of them
um worked through or that they were they
were
um that was weighing down on them while
they were presenting
their um work to me and while they were
creating their
uh their art every day so
um when i was looking at this
as an entire body of interviews um you
know i worked with people from really
varied backgrounds who were in different
artistic mediums
but really what struck me was that all
of them
enacted what i um termed preservation
which is a form of collective memory
um so their work is adjacent to news me
to a news media landscape that both
excludes palestinian and syrian
self-representation
it's important to note here that i in my
work don't conflate palestinian and
syrian identities or conflate
palestinian and syrian experiences they
are quite different
however um there are no there are
cultural similarities and there's also a
lot of solidarity work between these
communities
um that um led me to um
put these into a comparative analysis so
their artists work in acts processes of
preservation
through collective memory building via
social media and in-person platforms
um through a coherent body of work that
is neither stagnant nor actively
dissipating
um there's a recognition of historical
erasure they maintain
critical identity constructs in diaspora
and they use their geographical distance
to build
more protected infrastructures of
representation
in ways that some of the communities at
um in in their um the
ethnic identities that they identify
with um the ways that they might
be unable to at certain times um
this also extends post-memory literature
into a future orientation
so this is necessarily predicated on a
group's experiential reality of an
existential threat
to their identity so such a threat
motivates the art to act as both a
carrier of aesthetic
experience as well as a museum of
historical reference
um basil talks about this when he um
discusses
uh videos of footage of isis and he said
it's like the last thing that represents
syrian people is daesh
and yeah in fact like they they like
these are the people who are working
actively erase the memory of syrian
culture
who are actively destroying
well-preserved ruins from the beginning
of time to create their own dynasty and
whatever
yet these are the people were attaching
syrians people think of syria
this is one is one of the first things
that comes to mind
and so basil really critiqued the
uh perpetuation um that
um especially recently in the news that
always rhetorically connects
isis with syrian communities um while
um so they both kind of fetishize this
connection
while also hollow out syrian historical
and cultural identity
that is very rich and very different
from anything relating to
isis um and tarik said we're not
fighting to just be free of occupation
we're fighting we're fighting to amplify
these beautiful components of the
culture
that do not get heard because of the
occupation right like it's a different
angle by which to take this it's not oh
we want to stop being killed
it's oh we want to live and and this
idea was really
um was at the forefront of
what heart talked about because of the
really common phrase that palestinians
like
um uh exist to resist and
he brought up what happens when we are
no longer having to resist
what happens when we then live in a
place where we have
some sort of self-determination we want
to have a society where we can
uh be able to bring our
expertise or our you know education
really to the forefront
so the idea with these people is that
the artists are preserving traditional
cultural values and practices within
contemporary work that can be altered
reimagined or imported into future
communities so this was also
our conversations were often marked by
references to 9 11
and how this had a an effect on their
own self-conception of their identities
whether it was
one of the artists recalled an incident
where
his teacher in the classroom um jokingly
told him to not
use an uzi to shoot up the classroom um
but we also have like someone like sammy
talking about how
911 really um it wasn't that he didn't
know at all that he was arab american
before
but it was after 9 11 that he began to
understand what being arab american
meant
within a u.s um within a u.s
space so there i don't want to go too
much longer here because i want to get
questions
um but i do i'll briefly go over some of
this um
that there are uh i talk about three
specific modes of preservation
um from these interviews and they're
having to do with form tradition and
relationships
and in terms of form a great example was
dj fetten
um she often performed for
um both within palestinian communities
but also within
the wider muslim communities in her area
and she saw it as really a service to
the community
um because a lot of the traditional
celebrations like for weddings
uh a lot of times there was a need for a
woman to be able to
play music or entertain at these
cultural events
and so she was able in in this in these
instances to preserve some of the
cultural tradition in terms of music
or the celebrations themselves but also
start to bring in kind of more
egalitarian views about women in the
service industry
so i talk about with this with other
artists like chris as well
there was a lot of talk about food and
land chris made a comment that i just
see fazal i made a comment that i just
love which is i may not have grown up
speaking fluent arabic
but we ate fluent arabic you know um
and i'm reflected on this when she said
that um
you know she was talking about the
differences between syria and palestine
and taboola
for example so food is often a really
important
holder of memories that has an effect
affective
and also material relationship between
the people
and and their um their uh their wider
communities
um uh see gosala chris talked about how
the mint from his grandmother's garden
allowed him for when he arrived in
israel
his actually u.s neighbors who had who
also had israeli citizenship
picked chris up from the airport
and how when he looked down and saw mint
that it reminded him of
home it reminded him of his palestinian
grandma's mint
that she the garden that she had kind of
recreated in the u.s
um so i would love to go over this poem
um i just want to i don't have time to
read over it but this is
almost food and land poem and it is
incredibly powerful and moving i would
really recommend i'm going to looking at
my grandmother's farm
and she talks about the role of food in
um
in persisting through the um the current
uh the the war in syria and
um thinking about having to rebuild
after the war
and i just got rid of my video um so i
also talk about textiles such as tetris
the kefia for both syrians and
palestinians as well as the importance
of flags in their work
um i talk about relationships um having
to do with religion which is really
important particularly
for ammo who um talked about
the the way in which uh
the war in syria really um
reconstituted certain relationships
having to do with faith
among syrian communities as well as for
palestinians and the relationship
between
palestinian and or christian and muslim
palestinians
and i also talked about
intergenerational relationships and how
this really comes into a lot of their
work
and preserving certain um certain
traditions and understanding family
structures but also trying to
also kind of that tension between first
and second generation and third
generation
immigrants in a in a different country
trying to kind of hold on to
some of these traditions while also
progressing in a certain way
so i talked about um i'm only going to
briefly go over this
race and preservation through instances
of solidarity
this was really important for a lot of
the artists because
they've been called racial slurs but
many of them also grew up
among other communities of color
where they felt like they belonged much
more so
than in in the in white communities and
so there were um they grew up with these
solidarity solidarities with them um but
also
uh all of them spoke to the importance
of having
of um carrying out solidarity work
as part of their work with their own
community
so in conclusion um some of the the
summary is that whiteness as an ideology
and contemporary use christian rhetoric
uphold racial hierarchy in the u.s as
pertains to arab immigrants and refugees
and there is seemingly internalized
whiteness among arab americans
and identifying with whiteness as an
ideology rather than a phenotype
um is highly correlated with negative
views towards incoming arab refugees and
immigrants
um i also found that arab content
creators are aware of media messages
their effects
and they take steps to preserve their
historical traditions
while also anticipating a complex and
generative future
in which this idea of being able to
quote unquote practice
and being able to
have a very thorough knowledge of their
relationship to tradition uh will allow
um the the carrying on of those uh
within the more egalitarian space in the
future
and i have several other projects
underway um right now that
look at interventions and devices and
stereotypes and i think most importantly
going back and connecting this to the
beginning
is that they also look at um i'm
starting a project that looks on how
immigration policies in like in
particular
um can have uh impacts on um
arabs and iranians for example um so i'm
not gonna go over anything else
i'm just going to stop here
so i'm going to
go this way okay thanks
have i unshared my screen thank you nope
uh
okay let me stop sharing there we go
great thank you laura um
i'm i i have a a bunch of questions and
i'm just going to ask one to start
things off and and then
let others jump in um
and that was uh it relates to
um the the final section of your
presentation just now
um about the various different artists
that you interviewed
and um so the way that
you um described their work um
in in one of the slides was that it
existed
adjacent to the kinds of
media representations negative media
representations
um that your your more
quantitative work uh addresses
um and and you talked about
the um those artists seeing
or you spoke about the artist's work in
terms of preservation
and and i'm just wondering whether um in
your interviews with the artists
whether um
whether they characterize their their
work
uh as uh challenges
to um the like broad media
uh stereotypes of of
arabs and muslims
in which case the audience would be
a broad audience as well right sort of
like engaging with those stereotypes on
the larger
realm of popular culture and media
versus um working
to the the the kind of preservation work
that you're describing
in some ways implies a kind of
an audience of others within
the same or connected communities and
and kind of building
a certain kind of strength from below
right
as opposed to using their media
work you know cultural and media work
as a a way of
of combating stereotypes on this larger
stage so
yeah i'm wondering about those two kind
of modes of
media politics or cultural politics
and and how they're articulated by the
artists
you spoke to great thank you that's a
yeah a really important question
and um it actually so first to address
whether or not
they themselves addressed media
stereotypes or who their audience was i
think is is really what we're getting at
here
and it was split down the middle for the
most part um
i will say that really
particularly palestinian-americans were
not speaking to
a different outside audience they were
not trying to
combat certain stereotypes uh for the
most part those uh palestinian-americans
were instead
um really kind of more focused
within their own community but with the
hope
and with the um additional the goal
would be
that other communities could you know
view their work witness their work
see their work um and then um have some
sort of way to kind of
have access to this conversation whereas
really
the syrian american artists that i spoke
with
were much more kind of outward looking
in in terms of who their audience was
so they mostly were trying to
either represent syrian americans
syrians in general to
audiences that were not of their own
communities
so they were speaking to their
communities they were speaking in
solidarity
but by and large um
they were trying to kind of enact a type
of educational experience
um for uh for
people in the us or um globally
and um so that is part of the first
question
and i'm trying to remember so that then
part of that also gets into um being
adjacent to the media and i think that
that's
i use that very carefully because often
times um there is the
kind of over determination of the word
resistance and i think we often like to
attribute
um that everything that communities who
have been marginalized or oppressed in
some way
that everything they do is resistance
but i think to some extent that also
then
serves to re-center um those narratives
that are harming their communities
and so they exist in the space where
they acknowledge that these occur
they know it it's weighing down on them
but i think that for the most part
they are trying to create um
objects or trying to speak in such a way
that they can
show unity with their people that they
can um
whether showing them something beautiful
or whether it be showing them something
that they can relate to when they're
walking down the street
um that those communities are
that they're they're just trying to
connect with them they're not
necessarily trying to combat a specific
media stereotype
was there can you remind me clear
another no you covered everything that i
asked
asked about that's great thank you
um so there uh uh why don't we
see are there a couple of questions that
have come up in the q a
um but also i wanted to just see if
anyone immediately
um has a question emily
yeah thank you and laura thanks very
much for the wonderful presentation
very comprehensive um so i had a
question about your earlier
quantitative media effects research you
were talking about how
um participants who identified as white
only
often held the assumption or the the
belief that um
immigrants and refugee communities
needed to um
kind of act happy or uh kind of present
gratitude for being in the u.s or else
they should leave
um and that reminded me of uh in econ
the lump of labor fallacy which um is
that like immigrants coming in
only really take up jobs and don't also
create demand for jobs
um so i was wondering whether you've
seen in your own research or
other research um whether being
presented with information about how
immigrants contribute in various ways to
communities or the economy
whether like by you know accelerating
innovation or
paying taxes or taking jobs that um
citizens often don't want to take uh
it sort of attenuates those feelings
that they need to be grateful or act
happy
just sort of thoughts about that yeah
thank you emily that's a fantastic
question
i i kind of work along that line of
research and
in other things that i do as well and um
i
i did measure in term um so
so what you're talking about um is
something that i
sometimes deem respectability politics
um which when it comes to refugees and
immigrants can mean that
um there has to be a narrative that
these communities contribute
most often fiscally to united states
economy
in order to be um worth it or
or to be deserving of being able to come
into the united states
and so you walk this really tight rope
between
acknowledging that you're that really
arab
arab communities and iranian communities
in the united states
actually do and they are known for their
entrepreneurial
capabilities they have been to be honest
some more of the middle class to even
upper class in terms of immigrants in
general
and um they're highly educated we see a
lot of
um arab americans um also becoming
physicians
so they do occupy this place but on the
flip side of that that same rhetoric
then
can also serve to limit who is allowed
to come into the united states
and that's what we've also seen with
this new public charge
rule and with subsequent um
quotas put on um on on immigrant
communities
that really limit how many communities
can just be able to be accepted into the
united states for just being a refugee
and so um there there is the extent to
which
um like humans of new york um honey has
you know ran a great series on syrian
refugees a few years ago
and so things like that do have the
capability to somewhat
humanize or or um bring
positive information about a group to
the wider public
but then you also have situations where
um i had
or i completed a study on all of the
uh news reports about um
the executive order that i talked about
in the beginning that prevented
muslim or communities from muslim
majority countries from entering into
the united states
and i found that most of those stories
for the exceptions or people that really
should be let in
that it typically focused on the
military or it focused
on um people who were
families that were split up and so what
really happened were communities who
well they're escaping war they're
they're fleeing
violence um that that wasn't deemed as
a important enough exception to
to um be granted asylum for example or
be granted an exception
so that is something that's been studied
a lot and and it
it's really hard to find the balance of
using that type of information to
humanize and really broaden
knowledge about these communities but
also not reinforce something that
is harmful to these communities in the
first place which is this idea of
respectability
so did that
answer your question yeah thank you very
much
hi laura thank you so much uh i have a
like in the last part you talk about
intergenerational relationships and i
was wondering
how do you think like media narratives
can generate
uh disparities in these relationships
if you think they can how they can
um you mean how they can kind of
complicate
the intergenerational relationship yeah
so interestingly
i think i had it on my slide i didn't
get to it but almost every person
referenced remy the show rami which um
he uh you know he's one now right a
golden
a golden globe or an emmy for the show
it's a very it's a wildly popular show
and it's it's about um
a man who's egyptian american
and he kind of has to deal with
balancing all of the this like
intergenerational expectations
um and understanding what it really
means to be egyptian american
in the united states at this particular
time um
and kind of carrying all the to some
extent the burden of what the family
expects of him
and cultural and traditional values
while also trying to
um fit in or be part of
a u.s society so i think um
what i've seen and i
don't know if i can speak to shows as a
whole but i i'll use this as an example
that i've seen a lot of arab americans
really relate to it and i think it's um
it's something that
there's there have been criticisms on it
that maybe that remy doesn't always
present
a really complicated narrative about
women um and i think that he did a
better job with that in the second
season
but what i've seen by and large is that
people feel like they're being seen or
feel like this idea of being in this
liminal space
of caught between two cultures where
they are feeling
pulls from different generations that is
something that they can relate to and
also it almost gives them
like not just a language to use when
speaking to friends
but it's almost something like they see
it and then they can talk to a friend
and they're like oh you saw that like oh
yeah that happens all the time
and i think we see that a lot too
increasingly with like youtube videos
that there's a lot
of um you know for second third
generation immigrants creating youtube
channels and
being like and kind of showing this
tension and so i think that it can be
really productive
um for um for second third generation
immigrants or refugees or asylum seekers
who um maybe realize that other people
have these experiences but i think that
there's a lot of
attention around and i think even the
portrayal of it is that it's not it
doesn't always have to be frustrating
either that at certain points it can be
kind of funny
or it can create really um
beautiful moments between generations
where they they can
have a space to come together so um
i think i mean i love remy i think that
other shows that are
um similar um like even jane the virgin
is a really nice example too
um that they can be really um useful and
helpful for people to have conversations
on topics where they might not know
where to start otherwise
um i'm gonna take a couple of the
questions that have
come in on chat and in our q a
and the first was
earlier on susannah who's one of our
alum
asks uh what does the concept of a
unique
safe haven for christians and or jews
in a discourse with american christians
mean
uh she says that confused me
christianity is the world's predominant
religion right
is there some implication that
christians are persecuted globally
the answer is yes there is the
perception among american christians and
specifically evangelical christians that
christians are persecuted globally um
and this has been something that has
really i would say has really um
intensified since perhaps the 1980s um
and the increasing rise of some of the
like for example
um liberty university jerry fowle jr um
in in the last presidential election we
saw that
christians were quite upset that um
president obama uh brought in syrian
muslims and they just couldn't
understand why
he would be bringing in syrian muslims
to the united states who are refugees
because
they're like oh well isis is is also
muslim right and so without
understanding some of these really
complicated nuances
um and and showing up and and wondering
why there wasn't a preference
for syrian christians to be um resettled
over syrian muslims so um there
there is this notion that uh christians
are persecuted globally
that they are increasingly being
persecuted
and targeted in the united states we've
seen this also with the idea of the war
on christmas
um for example and so a lot of
evangelical um christian commentary or
rhetoric
does uh kind of construct us as a safe
haven as some sort of unique place
which really does also kind of harken
back to earlier christian communities
whether they
in the 1900s 1800s that viewed
the us as a new israel to christians
and for this community and so this
unique safe haven for christians and
jews also comes out of
a lot of my findings that have shown
that christians really believe
that they are much more similar and
related to
um and hold the same values as american
jews for example
than they do american muslims and so
um for many american christians there
has been this kind of division where
they see it
even they call it judeo-christian belief
systems
and and that muslims do not fit into
that narrative
and so measuring that was more so a
measure of
um kind of this this rhetoric that uh
situation has a situation where
christians are perceived to be
um globally persecuted more than other
face at the moment
or that they're being increasingly
persecuted and that in the u.s there's a
risk of losing
uh personal freedoms so that's really
where that came
out of um kind of this idea of
isolationism
uh nationalism um but also some of these
these binaries between christians and
other religious communities
so i don't know if that answers the
question susannah
that's a that's a great question and
definitely needs explanation so
okay great great
um so i'll take another uh question
from this is from q a from from our
uh attendees and this is from uh
kimiya jalalipur and the question is
could you expand
on why you think the internalization of
white ideology may occur
among arab americans or other
marginalized communities
yeah thank you camille for that question
that is a great question
in my mind the internalization of
whiteness does come from
what we've seen originated with
delegation of whiteness
in the earlier 1900s and this pressure
to either assimilate or adopt
certain practices that align with
whiteness so as to
avoid um marginalization and so over
time
the weight of avoiding margin or trying
to avoid um certain instances of
marginalization
has in some cases resulted um
with that that internalization of
whiteness as an ideology
uh in order to um uh
potentially avoid um experiencing
um negative consequences that other
marginalized communities may experience
or really that they've been so
socialized into this white ideology
that it's something that is part of
their um
their uh worldview or part of who they
are just as a person growing up in the
u.s
so i think there may be a number of
reasons for this and i think that would
have to be something that would be
studied
with a much much larger participant pool
as well
great thank you um i don't know uh there
are
there are a couple more q a questions
but i thought i would
bring it back to um see if there are any
questions from
uh our graduate students is it possible
let me just
um throw up
oh you can't see my i unshared it
um if anyone is interested in asking me
some of those questions
uh you can always email me them at
alpartene elpartanetmit.edu
sorry go ahead my apologies for that for
interrupting
no no problems um uh so i'm i'll go to
another
q a question um and that
is from hamid reza nasiri
and
[Music]
who writes there is this issue of
looking at refugees by either being kind
to them or rejecting them
while the root cause of having of of
having been
refugees is ignored so when we have
syrian or honduran refugees there is
that binary perspective but little
conversation on the significant
impact of u.s interventions in those
places
in causing mass migrations the 2009 coup
in honduras
or the role of the us inciting war in
syria are not discussed
so the question is i'm curious if you
ask your interviewees not just about
their sympathy or openness
um but about their responsibility toward
refugees
for the wrongdoings of their own
government
then i think he follows it up with to
clarify asking about the surveys from
u.s citizens especially but also maybe
how the artists think about that issue
thank you um thank you so much for that
um that is a such an important
um question that really uh gets at the
heart of a lot of which
what i do which is trying to be able to
uh bring to light not only some of the
underlying
colonialist or imperialist policies uh
that further demonize these communities
um and also
um but they also in many ways contribute
to the displacement in the first place
so i think that is something that um
very much
uh needs to be looked into in in this
current work i did not
look into that but i think that is
actually a really fantastic
way to go forward in a different
direction would be to get some of these
um would be to get reactions from
participants if it's reframed
instead of something that these
communities are fleeing from
you know you know usually the um
the uh event or the the instance from
which they are fleeing is often
uh you know it's unrooted or unmoored
from its origin
right and so it just happens that's what
oftentimes these like events are just
seem to happen or it just happens over
there
because of their history or their
identities and so i think that um it
would be really interesting to bring
that to participants to
um maybe instead fragrance them as their
accountability
and being and being part of a democracy
that has democratically elected
representatives who
do have some influence over um us
policies abroad
so um i didn't ask them about that i um
the artist that i talked with um we did
have many conversations and
understanding the
uh political relationships between the
us
and um different governments around the
world so so that is something that we
talked about quite a bit
but um i really love this question i
um gosh i need to conduct another
uh experiment with this question so
thank you so much
okay um and yeah i'm gonna go back to
our our group online here to see if
there are any other questions
and there's one more in the q a
that i can get to as well
okay okay i'm going to go back over to
the the q a
and laura you can probably you see this
too right so the question is
does the editorial position slash makeup
of the us media matter in other words do
you
um oh do you
i guess do you show the same story
presented by
al jazeera fox news and msnbc
oh do you think it must be there's a
missing word but
um would generate differing results if
shown to the same control
audience okay that is a good question
thank you jonathan
um the first question seems a little bit
different from the rest of it even
though i i think they are related
um i do think that the editorial
position or i do
think that the um that it matters who is
presenting these stories i think that
even what i found with my survey
participants
is the criticism that by and large um
conversations on their communities did
not come
from the communities themselves they
were not rooted in
in the historical demands or goals of
the communities themselves
so i think that um the representation
and
um in all levels of media and media
production
is absolutely necessary relevant and
does have an effect on the types of
stories that are being put out
in terms of do i think the same i think
you're asking if i think the same story
presented on different news stations
would generate different results and the
answer is yes i do um
which is why i used the same i used
every
abc i think um for that um i didn't use
fox news or msnbc on purpose i didn't
use al jazeera on purpose
um because very much what we can see
with
um with politics right now in this
country
is that polarization doesn't only just
occur from what's being said
but really from the source that's saying
it and um
so i think that uh right now with ideas
of fake news or legitimacy that it was
important for me to keep
the news station the same
because in that experiment
i didn't manipulate the new station so
in the future
that would definitely be something and
i'm sure that other people have
manipulated news stations and other
experiments
and my experiment would have gotten too
big but yeah the answer is yes i think
that's a great great point and it would
affect i think
participants
all views well we've gone over time but
um uh
okay i'm just waiting to see if any any
other questions are there i have more
questions but we'll
have to do that offline at some point so
um thank you so much um that was really
a wonderful talk and um
and we um look forward to hearing
within our own community here hearing
more about your work and
and um uh thank you
so much thanks thank you to everyone uh
who's here today
okay all right take care everyone
thank you